good morning everyone
really happy to see so many people here
I'm really happy to be back in Oslo this
is truly one of the best conferences to
go to in Europe and to show our
appreciation before we get started could
we please give a round of applause to
the organizers
thanks this is also going to confuse
everyone else that's not in this room
all right so this is about what's new in
c-sharp some of the features that have
been added the past few years or
actually the past decade and also some
of the things that we are going to
expect in newer versions of c-sharp I
usually joke and say that c-sharp is
turning into F sharp and I'm gonna stop
making that joke because the truth
actually hurts quite a bit
but in all honesty c-sharp is taking
inspiration from so many different
programming languages not only F-sharp
but also Java kotlin Swift and all of
the other amazing programming languages
but what the they are doing with the
language is that they were making it a
part of c-sharp so that we as c-sharp
developers are familiar with those
features
so my name is Philip Ekberg if you do
have any questions after this talk send
me an email
it's funny no one told me that I forgot
to put my email on my slides I've been
telling people to email me for years I
never received any emails but now it's
out there send me an email if you have
any questions
so c-sharp has gotten all of these
amazing language features added to it in
the past decade things such as generics
async and weight and pattern matching
are some of the things that
architecturally change how we look at
our Solutions we can architect our
applications a little bit differently to
make them more readable more
maintainable and honestly a little bit
more fun to work with
while we're not going to be able to
cover all of this here I I just got out
of a two-day workshop going into detail
on all of these different language
features so we're not going to be able
to cover everything in depth but I'm
going to give you some inspiration to
what c-sharp has been improved with over
the past few years
and what's interesting with c-sharp and
also VB if you if you like that
programming language it's all open
source you can go on to GitHub and you
can participate in discussions around
what to get into the language you can
ask the language designers why they
would want to add some certain features
and you can also see what other
developers are expecting from these
features
so not everyone knows that c-sharp has
been open source for quite some time so
it's easy to follow along with the
progress of the language
they've done all the things such as
records pattern matching all of those
improvements have all been done through
GitHub open discussions getting
inspiration from other programmers out
there that are using the language
because honestly if you build a product
if you're not getting some feedback it's
really hard to know if people actually
like what you're doing
and I'll show you this later but there's
one language feature that they added
into c-sharp as a preview feature and
then they got a lot of community
backlash no one wanted this language
feature so they removed it
funnily enough everyone at Microsoft
thought that this is going into the
language everyone was using the preview
version and added it to their
repositories so all of a sudden everyone
had to go back and refactor their
application a second time
so don't always jump on the preview
features
so if we want to use the latest version
of c-sharp how do we do that
now some of the language features
require a particular runtime for example
c-sharp H requires dot net core 3.1 if
you want to use
c-sharp9.5 and so forth
now this is because some of the language
features require things in the runtime
as well in the.net SDK
I tend to say in the framework but it's
very confusing because there's no longer
any.net framework
now if you require some of the language
features that also require a runtime
change you will have to have both the of
course the compilers as well as the
runtime installed and you get that with
the latest version of Visual Studio
but an unsupported feature of this is
that you can in fact use a c-sharp 12
feature for example that doesn't require
a runtime or dot net
type you can use that for older versions
of net as well because it all just is
compiler magic or just uses compilation
to translate this into the IL which is
then also compatible with older versions
of the runtime
so that's quite cool
so with that being said we're going to
be looking at quite a lot of features
from c-sharp 8 through all the way to C
sharp 12.
but before we get into c-sharp 12 and
what's coming in the future I want to
talk about some highlights from c-sharp
8. there was quite a lot of language
features added to this iteration of the
language now you would imagine that once
you've gone to the eighth iteration of
your product you would be finished
that's not the case and if that was the
case I wouldn't be standing here
so some highlights from C sharp eight
they introduced a truly true way if
you're doing read-only members you can
have default interface methods I'm going
to look at a few of these in just a
moment switch Expressions which is
pattern matching enhancements some using
declaration static local functions
there's a lot of things that was added
in c-sharp 8. that will help us express
ourselves a little bit differently
I've highlighted a couple of these here
which are the important features pattern
matching enhancements using what's
called switch Expressions which we're
going to dig into we're going to look at
some nullable reference types and
asynchronous streams this is just to get
you up to speed about what's added to
c-sharp over the past few years
before we talk about the useful features
there's one feature called default
interface methods or default interface
implementations
I normally say that this is dividing
developers into two groups
some people love this feature
actually I haven't met anyone that loves
it so either you hate it or you just
don't like it
so with this feature look at this
interface here I've I've deployed this
to my all my users I have a million
users on GitHub that's using my
interface and all of a sudden I want to
extend this with more methods
if I do this if I add a method to this
interface everyone that's using my
package will then have to implement that
new method which is a little bit
annoying especially if you're a library
developer
so what's the the best way to fix this
why not allow you to actually have a
method implementation on your interface
so while I'm using an expression body
member here to create this method
implementation this could have been a
normal method body
so now my interface knows how to execute
code and obviously this requires a
runtime change
because previously no one expected that
an interface which is a contract would
be able to actually execute some logic
so this is good if you're a library
developer I've seen people use this to
introduce converters and whatnot I'm not
sure if this is the best approach to
introduce a helper class or doing
multiple inheritance but it's there
now in terms of useful language features
there's this thing called nullable
reference types
so in C sharp boring actually in all
other programming languages we've all
probably experienced
this
if you haven't welcome to the world of
programming this might be your first day
tomorrow you'll get this
but in all honesty if they were to
rebuild the compilers today just throw
everything out of the of whatever's
there in visual studio and in produce
c-sharp as a new programming language
they would make it really hard for
anyone to use nulls they do this in
kotlin in kotlin you have to explicitly
say that I want this to be null I want
to allow you to use nulls for this thing
and the compiler is going to smack you
on the fingers and tell you to not to
because it's not a good idea
the problem with null ability is that
we'll end up having null checks all over
the place it's going to clutter the code
with unnecessary if blocks or
unnecessary question marks or
exclamation marks in the case of C sharp
but also what does it actually mean to
return null from from a method
as an example if I have a repository
that fetches a user from a database
that returns null did that mean that I
couldn't find the user was the user
deleted
did I get an exception
personally I always return now so I
should probably listen to my own device
here and not do this because it's very
confusing it might make sense the first
time you write the code but in the long
run it doesn't
so instead a better approach would have
been to introduce standard objects or
default objects for example you inherit
from the user and have a not found user
or deleted user and you can then use
pattern matching to determine exactly
what that user is
it's better similar to nulls but it's at
least a little bit more understanding
what you're doing
and also introducing nulls in the
language means that we encourage objects
to be mutable that means that we can
change the state once I create an object
I don't want that to be changed at any
time without it being dereferenced
because there's going to be some issues
with multi-threading
if you're building multi-threaded
applications or applications that get
get data at the same time from different
places then you might end up having race
conditions and if you are objects that
are not immutable you'll end up having
some issues
so we can fix this we can of course look
for nulls all over the place but this
here is ugly
and someone's going to tell me well you
can write this much better obviously I
can write this if statement a little bit
nicer but introducing question marks all
over my code base it's not really the
best architecture or not the best
approach
while it's obvious what I want to do
here it's not very very nice
without if I tell the compiler to treat
all my nullables or all my reference
types as being not nullable
so what does that actually mean
it can enable this feature in a couple
of different ways
so traditionally this is a normal
c-sharp application but traditionally
everything such as an innumerable
or you know a normal string
they're all nullable and this
application doesn't give me any compiler
errors it doesn't give me any warnings
or anything like that
but when I enable this language feature
called nullable reference types
I can say nullable enable
and now all of a sudden it's going to
tell me or give me a little bit of a
squiggly here telling me that you have a
little bit of a warning here
we all know that as soon as we get a
warning in our compiled application we
go and fix that
everyone that's laughing you don't do it
I know I'm the same I just ignore all
the warnings
there's a fix for that as well so I want
to enable this instead of doing this per
class like it's a good option to be able
to if I want to refactor an older
version of my application I can go ahead
and enable this for a class a method
just a field if I wanted to do that but
honestly what I want to do here is that
instead of doing it per per line I want
to go into the project file
and say that I want to enable this
language feature
and now I've enabled these nullable
reference types
and I've also enabled another thing
called treat warnings as errors
this is probably the most amazing thing
that you can do in a project
so if I save this here
and I go back and all of a sudden we
have nullable reference types enabled
and instead of getting a warning I get a
compiler warn error I can no longer
compile the application because I
haven't guaranteed that this is set to
an instance
now another reference types in this this
type was introduced in C sharp eight
there is a there's a lot of improvements
to how we work with this coming in
c-sharp 11 as well but let me get to
that in just a moment
to get rid of these compiler errors
we have to guarantee that this is set to
an instance
so I could of course introduce a
Constructor and now if I do that it's
going to tell me that well the
Constructor of a class should be in
charge of instancing these objects
the problem with then changing this
first name String
last name I'm going to set these two
the corresponding values let's do last
name
and now I don't have any errors anymore
but then when I compile this application
everyone that's using this class is now
going to be incompatible not the best
approach
so we have two options I really don't
want to introduce a Constructor
and I'm going to get ahead of myself
here and show you a language feature of
c-sharp 11 that allows us to get around
this problem
I can say that this is required
if I can spell this there we go
I can now say that anyone that's
creating an instance of this has to set
this value
and they can do that in the object
initializer which is very different from
introducing a Constructor
because anyone that's deserializing this
if you're using system.text.json which
is the built-in Json serializer in.net
it will look for required properties and
if it's not available in your Json that
you're deserializing you'll get an
exception if you're trying to create an
instance of this class without setting
this first name in The Collection
initializer it's going to tell you that
you have a problem
so if we require this here
and you might have also spotted that I
have another keyword here called init
only this is from C sharp 9 where I say
that you can initialize this but you can
only do it once so after that this is
going to be immutable so we're required
to set this but then you cannot change
it
I could set it to set and then it's no
no longer immutable but that's not a
good idea
so I want to require the first name but
honestly I don't want to um require the
last name for some reason
so there was a few different ways to
solve this as well but I just want to
allow this to be set to null and this is
the nullable reference type I can now
say that a reference type is allowed to
be set to null so you introduce a
question mark
all right so now the problem wasn't
really in this class the the nullable
the null reference exceptions would have
occurred where someone uses this class
and that would have been so let me just
do the same thing for where this class
is used this wouldn't be set to
reference null reference exception
either this wouldn't throw anything so
I'm going to say that I allow this class
to also be set to null when you
instantiate this person class
now if I expand this method here I know
that this here gave me a little bit of a
compiler error as well
so the compiler is really smart here it
knows that you have something that could
potentially be null and I can say that
well
I want to do perform a null check I know
that details can be null this is a
nullable reference type last name can
also be null and then all of a sudden
I've performed the appropriate null
checks
without enabling this language feature I
wouldn't have known that this would have
been a potential null reference
exception
but you don't have to end up doing
question marks all over the place
can also the compiler is really smart IT
introduces something called null State
static analysis so that it keeps track
of if you've performed a null check
so I could say well if person
dot details is no
continue
if person dot details dot last name is
no
continue
and then it knows that I've performed
these appropriate null checks and of
course we could write this in many
different ways but this is just to
illustrate that it's not going to
complain about details here because if I
don't do this
Republic complain that I'm not doing the
null check here
so now I can do this in many different
ways
it's a quite powerful language feature
but it also knows that if I perform the
null check in another method that I call
and that method can then promise that
it's performing the appropriate null
checks
so an example of that would have been to
say there's a class called argument
null
exception throw if null
and I can say person dot details
and we could do the same for the last
name
and now it knows that this method
promises that if this is null it's going
to throw an exception so it validates
this input argument and then tells me if
there's an exception I prefer or there's
no null references
compiler is doing a whole lot of smart
things here
so I know a lot of people that enable
this in their projects and I find a lot
of potential non-reference exceptions
which is better to do in compile time
rather than in runtime
there's another place in this
application
before I get to that let me show you
another option here if we remove this
I could also say that I'm smarter than
the compiler and say that I'm going to
damage give me the details this is the
damage operator
you think this is a good idea
Maybe
this was a fix to uh to get rid of not
having the required keyword previously
in in c-sharp 10 so you could say that I
require this to be non-null but the
default is null damn it
um not the best design anyways let's
keep it like that for now and then
instead we're going to go down here and
see that there's another problem I'm
saying that this here requires that I
return an instance of something that
implements I enumerable I could say that
it's potentially null or that it is
potentially contains potential null
references and in C sharp 13 you'll be
able to do question marks explosion work
all over the place
write the code for you
I'm kidding so I don't want to do that
honestly that is the last resort
allowing to return all is just to be
able to get this to into an older
application but doing this from scratch
is probably not the best idea so instead
I want to ensure that I've created this
instance I can do that by saying I want
to return
I want to yield return
something you can do yield return that
means I don't have to create a temporary
list I can use the target type new
expression to tell me just create a new
person
so the compiler will use this new
language feature called Target type new
expression to figure out what type it
needs to create and then give me an
instance of that
because I'm not required to create the
details class this is not going to give
me an exception
but look at what happens if I say I want
to also create a new instance of details
now it's going to give me a compiler
error here because I haven't set the
required property first name
so I can do that as well just to
illustrate exactly
how this works I can say first name and
look at that
an indent is a little bit nicer
it even tells us that first name is
required so visual studio will tell us
that you are required to set this to an
instance
right
there we go
set it to an instance
probably not the best idea
so while you think you are smarter than
the compiler
you're most certainly not therefore we
should set this to some default value
maybe we do string dot empty instead if
you want to do that
you get the idea right so we can set it
to a default object instead which is not
null
so the nullable reference types allow us
to quickly find places that could
potentially cause exceptions and we can
enable and disable this I don't I can't
only enable this but I could say that
nullable disable for this method if it's
causing a little bit of nuance in my
upgrade or I can enable it for certain
portions
all right so with that being said
I do recommend that you turn this
feature on and while I do usually I joke
and say you should turn this on and
check in your code and just leave work
you should actually try this it will be
such a fun social experiment turn it on
and just check in your code and go on
vacation
summer will fix the code I promise
so with C sharp eight we also got this
thing called asynchronous streams which
is a quite powerful language feature it
allows you to consume and produce
streams of data I have a talk later
today on building asynchronous
programming in c-sharp and doing that
efficiently it's at three o'clock so
we'll quickly just go through exactly
what this language feature is doing
basically I can consume a stream of data
like this here so what does it actually
mean to then say I want to await a for
each Loop
let's jump over to visual studio again
and I have a sample for this
so what I can do here is that I can say
I have this await for each that's going
to retrieve elements asynchronously
so to create one of these it probably
makes more sense if you look at how to
produce a stream of elements I have a
method called read async which is going
to produce an i async enumerable of
string which means that it can give me
strings on the Fly basically it could be
retrieving them from a message bus let's
say an Azure message queue could
retrieve it from a disk memory whatever
doesn't matter the idea is that I get
one element at a time I don't know how
many I'm gonna get but as soon as I get
the elements I'm going to be happy and
this is of course marked as being async
I'm using a language feature from C
sharp 8 called using declarations so I
can say using VAR stream this means that
once this Method All completes and
finishes it's going to dispose of that
disposable type so I no longer have to
wrap my entire code inside a using
statement
and then I have some a while loop here
that's saying I want to read the next
line from a phylon disk
I'm using pattern mashing which we're
going to talk about in just a moment to
say that as long as this is an instance
of a string I'm going to capture this in
a local variable which is only available
inside the scope of this while loop
it's quite handy the previous versions
of C sharp if you did this in C sharp 8
or C sharp 7 you'd have to write a
little bit more code than than this here
so not only does it validate that it's
set to an instance it also capture this
into the local variable co-line
I can then say I want to process this
line this might take some time it might
be sending it off to another queue and
waiting for that response might be
storing it to disk or whatever you get
the idea
it's an asynchronous process that takes
a little bit of time doesn't matter what
it's doing
and then I use yield return now yield
together with the I async enumerable is
what's making this magic work so this
here will indicate to the iterator that
it's now a new element available to
process
and honestly the async and await
keywords together with the iasync
enumerable and yield keyword there's a
lot of context switching and jumping
between threads and to make this work
it's it's really quite amazing
so now this produces a stream now
normally you might use a producer like
the Azure SDK for example to say connect
me to a a message queue
so maybe you don't write this portion of
the code but you do write the consumer
part of things which is this a wait for
each Loop
what you might have seen before is that
you say I want to iterate through all
the elements available in this chunk of
data so when you have a weight in front
of something it means that give me all
of that all of the result when you're
done
the await in front of the for each Loop
means that each element is going to be
retrieved asynchronously
so I'll give it a break point in here
and I'm just going to print that to the
console
if I put a breakpoint here I'll put a
breakpoint inside the while loop and I'm
going to run this with the debugger
attached just to make sure we run the
right project
and you'll see here that it it starts
reading one of the lines and then we get
up into the the for each Loop it
processes this I could choose now to not
continue break out of the loop and that
would stop reading from the Stream
but then when I want to read the next
element it goes ahead and reads that
comes back to my for each Loop when that
element is available
so if I release this this here is going
to show you my favorite song
I'm sorry
not really
all right so that's the asynchronous
streams they're quite powerful and I'm
using this together with that pattern
matching enhancements as well that we're
going to talk about next
so there's a lot happening in this code
snippet here even though it looks very
simple there's a lot of code generated
to make this work the task parallel
library to get with the with the
generated State machine it's doing a lot
of things internally
I'm just happy I don't have to write
that code myself
so also with C sharp 9 we got a thing
called records now records is another
way of creating a reference type this
was one of the language features they
wanted to add when they started the work
on the open source compilers
but apparently it was very difficult to
get this language feature created and
added to the language so therefore it
took a little bit of time
and one of the things you'll notice with
the work on all of these language
features is that they want to make it a
part of c-sharp they want to make it
feel like it's it's meant to be a
c-sharp language feature
although if anyone in here has ever done
c-sharp one it's very different today
but it keeps improving with every
version of the language and it feels
like it belongs in the current time
we looked at the ended only Setters
which is a way for us to create a
immutable or or
said only once Setter on a property
we have something called a top level
statement
we have pattern matching enhancements in
C sharp nine there's this target type
new Expressions which I showed you just
a moment ago and there's a whole lot of
more language features that are more
important if you are working with very
low level programming
there's some caching going on as well
there's a whole lot of language features
like even if this is the ninth iteration
of C sharp we're not going to spend time
looking at all of these here because
some of them are just important for very
specific use cases
but what we are going to to look at is
how to use record types and pattern
matching
and I didn't say this but we also have
this language features called top level
statements and let me show you this here
real quickly if you haven't seen this
before this here is actually a normal
program file so I don't have a public
static void main or anything like that
this here is the new style of writing a
console application for example but it's
also what you use if you want to create
something called a minimal API so
there's this new concept of allowing you
to quickly create a web application that
only lives in a console application like
this it's very simple to read and um
it's quite powerful
so with that being said we're going to
be talking a little bit about pattern
matching
so pattern matching was introduced as a
first iteration in C sharp seven but at
that point it didn't really make a lot
of sense because it required a lot more
code to express yourself and the whole
idea with pattern matching is that we
want to write less code and express
ourselves better and the code to make
sense
but I'll show you how to not make sense
in a moment as well
so pattern matching is all about
allowing us to determine what things are
so in this case here we could check if a
fruit is edible the color if the puzzle
piece is transparent what order these
things are in the the poster and so
forth
I like to talk about this like matching
on an attribute or matching on the type
and I'm not talking about the attribute
in terms of what you decorate a method
or a class with or a parameter but an
attribute as the color for example
so in C sharp one through six we've been
able to do this as well it's just a
little bit different you could say that
I want to get the type of what I'm
looking at and I can compare that to a
type of something and then I can also
check a property if that property was
only available on the subclass I'd have
to to cast it myself
we've all seen code like this here it's
it's nothing wrong with it but we could
probably improve on this a little bit
one of the the themes of improvements in
c-sharp is allowing us to write less
code to express the same idea
so that's why in C sharp 7 they require
a lot more code to express the same
thing
but this Builds on to what's coming in C
sharp 8 9 10 11 and 12. the improvements
to pattern matching so in this first
iteration of of pattern matching in C
sharp 7 there's quite a few things
happening in here the first thing is
that we can use that type as the input
to the switch
inside the case we can say if this is of
my type that I'm looking for I'm
capturing this to a local variable and I
can then also use it as the concrete
type without having to do sorry without
having to do any type casting
which is quite powerful
but at the time that C sharp 7 came out
I didn't use this a lot
but with C sharp 8 we got this thing
called a switch expression
this here is a little bit of a different
way of writing the pattern matching
using pattern matching we can also use
pattern matching with normal if
statements and elsif but this is a
really good addition to that so I could
say that this object I want to create
patterns for this to determine what this
is
and I fill this switch expression with
uh with expressions
which is determining what it returns so
here's an example of that I could say
that well I'm looking for a specific
type and then it's going to return some
data it doesn't have to
To Be Strings it's just a very simple
example
but it could also return critical column
method that returns a complex object
could return anything right
and then the underscore that's the
discard it's a way for me to say that I
want to match on anything I don't care
if it's null I don't care if it's even a
fruit in this case like I don't really
care at all
so that's a quite powerful powerful
pattern as well
now there are a lot of patterns so I
said that C sharp 8 and 9 and 10 and 11
introduces some enhancements to pattern
matching that's an understatement
because of course it's powerful enough
to be able to say what type is this but
I'd also like to be able to to check on
a couple of more things so we can we can
do a type pattern so this is all the
patterns available in c-sharp we're
going to jump over to some code and
explore this as well
we can all see something called a
positional pattern if we take an object
then we can deconstruct that and pull it
apart into different variables we can
also use that together with something
that looks like a tuple
we can match on property values we can
match on exact Tuple values or tuples or
however you like to pronounce that
we can use relational patterns so for
example let's say I want to find a
person that's over 30 years old I can
use a pattern to express that I can
group these together to for example say
people between 18 and 40 or 18 and 100.
I can use or to exclude elements I can
use parenthesize patterns negated not
recursive patterns and in C sharp 11 we
also got something called a list pattern
so now you know all about patterns no
kidding we're going to jump into visual
studio and actually look at how these
are applied
all right so before we look at the
pattern matching part I want to show you
this object that I've created here so
this here is is showing us a test result
which is obviously failed here if we
drill into this type it's using this new
thing called a record
a record is a reference type it gives us
quite a lot of things behind the scenes
it gives us value-based equality it
gives us immutability and it also is
defined by a primary Constructor
everything you use in the primary
Constructor will be available as a
public property
so I have another example of this I'm
going to swap over to another IDE
someone told me you have to start using
writer because it's the best IDE
available ever try to do this in my
workshop and crashed all the time
it wasn't a very good idea I blame the
HDMI cable
all right so I have this public record
called person doesn't have to be public
but it is now it has to to uh properties
available defining the primary
Constructor when I compile this this
will generate
I'm going to show you this here this is
looking at the lower level C sharp and
this is why I love Rider because I can
look at the IL or the lower level C
sharp but this decompiles into
so when you compile This Record it's
going to create a public class called
person it's going to implement I
equatable it's going to give you a
Constructor that lets you set the
backing fields
it's going to give you the properties
that are in it only you can only set
them once but they're public so you can
get that value out of the object
it's also going to implement two string
to be able to give a nice representation
of the object it's going to also give
you the operator overloads for
inequality inequality
which is very handy and if we scroll
down to what our equatable is actually
giving us we have this equals method
that takes a person
this here lets you
compare
the backing fields of for example the
name you compare that with the other
person's backing field of the name which
means that if you compare two reference
types if the records it's gonna compare
the properties
so for example
if we go back to this code here with the
with the test result if I do this this
twice like this here test result 2 this
would be
same
this would yield true because they have
the same values
now I'm using daytime offset.min value
here to make sure that they are in fact
identical a little gotcha with this is
that if I do UTC now or just now
they would have different ticks so they
would be inequal makes sense right
little side notes so that's why records
are truly powerful and they also give
you a deconstruct method out of the box
so I could say that
I could deconstruct this this test into
whatever the deconstruct method gives me
and if we look at what that means is
that it generates a method that has this
this annotation
or this notation it's called deconstruct
that's required it has a couple of out
parameters so it gives me a daytime
offset it gives me an integer and it
gives me a Boolean
so why is this important
because now I could say
if we go back to that file
here we go I could say I want to get the
the date some integer and a Bool
and now I could deref or deconstruct
this object into these three different
values
so why would you want to do this
this is important when it comes to
pattern matching because now I could use
these these positions to say that I want
to find the integer that is
greater than a certain value
so let me show you how to do that
we can do if test result
not that test result is
capable of being deconstructed into
something where that integer is more
than 10 and I don't care about the
Boolean
this code makes a lot of sense right
everyone will know what this is doing
so there are a couple of things that are
not good with this there's there's no
intellisense for what a deconstruct
deconstruct into so if I if I know I
have to know exactly what this what this
is called so let's go into test result
it's called dates since
I have to know exactly the casing and
exactly the name of it but I can use it
as a name parameter but this is a little
bit problematic because it means that
the code becomes a little bit unreadable
a better approach would have been to use
this with some of the other patterns
so you'll see you see here now that you
can use this with the if statement but
we can also say that I want to get a
result based on whatever this test
result is
I'm going to create one of these switch
expressions
and I'm going to say that okay I want to
find failed tests perfect I can do that
but I can also say it has to be a failed
test where the number of attempts are
less than or less than 10 and greater
than
let's see here
I could do this
I actually have to go the other way
around more than 10
and more than 20
sure this makes a lot of sense it does
or less than 20.
so I could do this to create a range
right it's going to be quite smart to
determining exactly what I'm looking for
so this here is a recursive pattern it
first checks that it's failed
and that it can have a property that is
that has this value
I could also say that
I don't care which type it is as long as
this is of an instance or an instance
yeah as long as this is of an instance I
can check that it has this property so
this will perform a null check and also
perform a check on the properties
you can write patterns that are very
confusing and you can write them
like this here where they quite make a
lot of sense
and of course we could also
um we could also use this with tuples
and other types as well
but where it's powerful let's say that I
just want to use this like it's it's
totally okay to use it to say if it's
failed
Let's uh
return
to failed page if uses an asp.net if
it's uh passed we're going to do
something else it's we're not going to
throw divide by zero exception
so that would be odd okay
and now we can also say for everything
else
we can just return 4 4.
right but what's interesting with the
Discord let's say that this here was
from a method call like I have the
object here so of course I could access
the properties of test result in this
case here but sometimes you might not
have the variable and as I said earlier
test result here we don't know if this
is an object or not so let's say here
I'm going to get the test date I can do
that because that's available on this
type let's do two string
and but if I do this and set it to an
object
test date doesn't exist on the object
makes sense right
so instead to get around that I can say
that well if it's a test or a result
I can use this as a local variable
inside that
switch instead or inside that that
expression
it's quite powerful
so you can write patterns that are truly
powerful and you can also write patterns
that make no sense at all so like with
any other feature in c-sharp and net and
other programming languages just be very
careful with how you use it and how you
add it it makes a lot of sense to use it
to find a certain property value
or for example in this case we're just
looking at the base types
now I do want to say this as well
because this is a question I get quite
often surely enough it's nice that I can
say if this is a fail test and I'm
looking for a particular property value
let's say number of attempts has to be
the number 10 but if I don't have this
as a constant how do I do how do I use
this
you would have to introduce another
approach
and say you want to capture this when
you have one over here when rest stops
number of attempts is more than 10 for
example you can do that as well so if
you introduce the when keyword you've
introduced a a when expression where you
can actually call methods so while this
will be very performant and and compile
time checks and so forth this here
will allow you to call method calls
which is one of the things I hear people
ask quite a lot
now in C sharp
in C sharp 11
or 12 let's see here we also got another
way of of working with patterns so I
have this list of people here and I can
say that if this this data
is
is empty
I want to do that this
more more frequently you might want to
say if it's not empty so I can negate
anything to say that it's not a certain
thing
obviously you can
negate anything like this right put not
in front of this and
who knows whatever that means now
so again you can write patterns that are
very confusing but also in this case
here it's quite obvious I'm looking for
data that is not empty
I could also say that I want to get a
result out of this here
to say that based on my data
or my list here I'm going to create a a
list pattern
where I can say well if it's empty I
want to uh
do something
but if there are elements
I
that damn divide by zero exception
I'm gonna blame the keyboard here we go
I could then say that this here is now
going to say that as long as it has or
not empties or this match is empty but I
could capture that range
to say that for example I'm going to
show you an example here I could say
that the first element in this array or
list of people
has to have a name
where the name is Philip
so the list patterns allows you to do
again recursive patterns I can say that
this list has to be of some sort
obviously a list of people isn't where
you would use this you could use this to
determine payload coming in from some
external system where you're looking for
certain bytes in the start or the end or
whatnot because I could say that I don't
care about what's in the middle I want
to make sure that the last element is
set to an instance and that the the name
is in this case Elise
so again you can write quite complex
complex things here
I could also say
while there's something in the middle it
has to start with A Philip it has to end
with Elise but I can also capture all
the elements in the middle
right so you can use this to slice off
portions of the array
makes it quite powerful
so pattern matching is a great addition
to the language but it also comes with
some responsibilities right we want to
make sure that our code is readable
maintainable and honestly fun to work
with
right so let's jump back into talking a
little bit more about what's been added
in C sharp 10. so with the records being
added to C sharp 9
they also increase record structs in C
sharp 10.
if you want to do that it's just about
where they are stored I gotcha with the
record structs is that they are not
immutable record classes are immutable
by default
but the record stocks are not you have
to also append the read-only keyword in
front of it to make it a read-only
record struct
because why be consistent
they also made some other improvements
they introduced a global using directive
and file scope namespaces so
you might have seen this
when I swapped over to Ryder I had this
namespace at the top here but I don't
have to wrap my entire class in this
namespace I can just declare the
namespace for the entire file at the top
again this is to make it easier to um
review code I guess so when you submit a
pull request reduce white space reduce
noise
they also made some changes to pattern
matching again to the property patterns
and did a whole lot of other
improvements to c-sharp 10.
so it's interesting to see that they're
still keeping adding important features
but some of these are less important
than what we've gotten in c-sharp 7 8
and 9 and the reason is that some of the
improvements in c-sharp 10 is to make it
better to write these minimal apis
one of the features that they're
allowing you to do is constant
interpolated strings so in this sample
here I'm creating an application name
called visma and I'm just using string
interpolation with a constant which is
something you couldn't do prior to C
sharp 10.
a little bit more of an important
language feature is when we're working
with lambdas so in this case here in
this is C Sharp eight
where I'm saying that I have a function
it will return an integer it takes a
string as an input and then it does
something but wouldn't it be nice if the
compiler could just infer this for us so
it's going to infer the type so with C
sharp actually this um
is a C sharp 9 even so in C sharp 10
you'd have to then you can then say bar
Parts in this case here and it will
infer whatever this function is actually
doing
which is nice so you know no longer have
to explicitly say what kind of action or
function you're doing because the
compiler will try to be very smart about
understanding exactly what's going on
here's an example of one of these
minimal apis
and also an example of one of the
c-sharp 10 features so you're able to
now have attributes in your lambdas so
that in this case here I have a very
simple application that is mapping the
root of the application to return some
data and I can say that it should get
that data from the content header but in
previous versions of C sharp you were
not able to do this and another
Improvement that they're making in
c-sharp 11 is that they are allowing you
to have default values in lambdas so I
could say that if you don't pass an ID
here the default is zero for example
which is also one of those features that
I don't understand white took so long
time to add this to the language
now with c-sharp 11 which is the current
version now we this was released in
November and we're not going to have
much time to talk about c-sharp 12 and
there's a reason for that they tend to
always talk about all the amazing
features they are going to add to the
language and then two days before they
release it they just scratch all of it
that makes my life very hard
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
c-sharp 11 instead we looked at these uh
these patterns these were added to
c-sharp 11 where you can match on the
contents of a list you can slice off
portions of a list
you might not know this but the syntax
that I used here
this here is the range syntax which is
also something that you use to slice off
data in an array so if I have a an array
of bytes for example I can say that I
want to slice off portions of that
I have an example of that in just a
moment
so we also got more patterns
improvements in in c-sharp 12 as well
where we are going to I can assure you
with that they're also introducing name
of parameter and finally they're caching
the uh the delegates for static method
groups now this might sound silly but
this is a huge performance hit in older
versions so it's quite important if you
use this it's going to be quite
performant
I showed you the required properties and
what's interesting with the required
properties is that you can now write a
little bit more fluent code there's
nothing stopping you from enabling this
this language feature of nullable
reference types because you can now go
ahead and enable that and set all your
properties to required and just fix some
of the places rather than having to
introduce a Constructor all over the
place
more keywords is better right so this
here is a required string called name
there's another language feature called
raw string literals
which I have an example of soon there's
something called Static members and
interfaces
there's also utf-8 string literals so
example a lot of the data that we're
getting from the web is all utf-8 but by
default or c-sharp is utf-16
so all the data that you work with
that's coming in from the web you have
to convert that into utf-16 and then you
can do processing with utf-8 there's a
lot of memory that you have to shuffle
around and it's just a little bit not
very performant so instead they allow
you to add the u8 at the end of a string
and this will give you a span of a byte
array or a read-only span of a byte
array actually
and this will let you do processing on
this string or this byte array
there's a generic math
there's generic attributes so this is
also one of those features if you've
been working with older versions of
asp.net you might have introduced your
own attribute class and you've never
been able to do it do a generic
attribute up until c-sharp 11.
now finally there's a thing called
parameter null checking
which they withdrew but some of you if
you haven't been keeping keeping up with
the language which why would you be here
if you have so
if we go into uh let's go to this this
class here now instead of me having to
perform this check here at the bottom
what they suggested was that
why not use double bangs
and it will automatically perform a null
check and throw an exception in your
face if this was null
imagine how many people like this idea
they refactored a whole lot of projects
internally or actually on GitHub so it's
not internal but a lot of internal
projects that will have people on
Microsoft working on them they refactor
a whole lot of things to use this while
it did reduce a bit of code it also adds
Some Noise having exclamation marks all
over the place it's not very readable
it's not very nice so due to a lot of
community backlash they had to remove
this language feature
which is nice which is one of the
reasons this being open source is a
great idea because we can participate in
the discussions and we can give ideas or
we can just tell them things we don't
like and they might listen and they
actually did in this this time
so the list patterns are quite complex
as well as I showed you earlier we can
grab the the middle elements and you can
use that then inside the uh the the
right hand side of that expression we
can make sure that a second element is
of a certain value we can say that I
don't care about the start of the
elements I just want to get all of it
so we can do quite a lot of things here
with that list pattern there's another
the other feature that is important is
string or raw string literals
where I could say that I'm using three
double quotes to say that I'm going to
write some code here now with XML I'm
not getting any
any syntax highlighting but I can use
the string interpolation here as well
if I jump over to uh to Rider
I think I have an example of that here
where I use this with Json
so I have I'm going to deserialize some
Json I'm using the raw spring literals
to say that here's my Json object that
I've defined inline and I'm getting some
syntax highlighting
it's also going to remove the white
space at this Frontier
so that's a quite nice feature
now I've mentioned the raw string
literals
or utf-8 string literals in this case
here I take my name I convert that into
a read-only span of bytes and then I can
say that based on this payload I want to
be able to then grab the index of the
first space where the index is also a a
utf-8
space and then I can use the uh the
range syntax together with with slicing
to say that I want to get my first name
and the last name
why is this important because this here
is the allocation free
it's a little bit of a lie because it
does allocate one variable to On On The
Stack here to hold the reference to that
array of or that that span of bytes but
it doesn't have to do any copy of my
content which is very performant and
it's very much better than having to
copy a race over all the time and do
some more processing the alternative and
the way that I use this before is to use
Link which is not the very most
performant thing to use for something
like this
they're also in producing a concept
called Static members and interfaces or
study abstract members in interfaces
we've always been able to do static in
interfaces but it just never gave us any
any
warning so here I have a static T inside
my inside my interface
there's no warnings that I haven't
implemented this on my class
so again why not just add another
keyword to this to actually enforce us
to implement what the interface dictates
so here I add the abstract keyword and
now it's going to tell me that you have
to implement this
I would have assumed that you had to
previously as well but for some reason
they they didn't enforce that
so that's all there is to C sharp 11.
now the question is what's next we have
another few minutes to talk about the
upcoming features
and I have a link here that's showing
all the progress of all the different
language features of.net and c-sharp
marshalling C sharp they have a GitHub
page where they're doing all of this in
the open they take comments from users
and they want to get the community
participation so that they know that
they work on the right thing
one of the things they want to add is a
concept called a primary Constructor
this looks very much like a record it's
a little bit different though so with
records you use a concept also called
primary Constructors which is very
confusing because they're very different
they are fundamentally different notice
how I have a a lowercase name here that
is to indicate that this is in fact not
a public property now it doesn't matter
that I have lowercase or not it's just
this is a field in my class it's not
going to create a property behind the
scenes when this is compiled and that's
where it's different from records
records the primary Constructor
introduces a public property but this
does not
slight difference so if you want this to
be publicly available you'd have to
first introduce that as well you have to
introduce it and you can use the primary
Constructor value to set it
and you'll see that if we decompile the
application
what it's doing is that we have we got
this Constructor and it's simply setting
it back in field
so it's a little bit different from
from the record
but this is not released yet so who
knows they might change it so take this
with a grain of salt
and then what they also want to add is a
default for or optional parameters in
Lambda expressions or also known as
default Expressions it's funny when you
read the documentations even the
official Microsoft announcement of this
they talk about this using two different
names
but it's the same language feature so
again with the consistency but they'll
get there once this is released in
November we'll know the name and
hopefully it will make it into the
language because for minimal apis where
I set up very small asp.net apis in a
small console application which can then
later grow into something bigger this is
a nice addition
means I don't have to introduce more
endpoints I can rather just add default
parameters
and don't use null as a default we've
already covered that
so I could call this with a with or
without a value doesn't really matter
and this would print my name to the
console
the final feature that they have
officially said that they are getting
into c-sharp 12 is the way to Alias
pretty much anything
this is an interesting language feature
so I'll go into my class and I'll say I
want to use the name point and whenever
I call something a point this should
refer to the Tuple or Tuple now we
haven't talked about this but in C sharp
7 they introduce the concept of tuples
or tuples whatever you want to call it
as a as a first class citizen in the
language this introduces a container of
sorts of just fields on a little class
very handy very useful feature so now if
I do this I'm going to say I want to use
the name point on the right call that
I'm going to get a tuple with two values
or two Fields so I can use this as an
input parameter and if you put Global in
front of this it's going to be globally
available throughout your entire project
quite a useful feature
but then again there's so much added to
c-sharp and there's probably a little
bit of confusion as well as to where the
language is going but just because
they're adding a language feature
doesn't mean that we have to jump on it
and use it
it's very nice to be able to come from F
sharp or kotlin or Java and find that oh
I have pattern matching available in
c-sharp I can somewhat take my code and
translate that into c-sharp if I need to
actually I don't personally translate
any code anymore I just paste it on a
very popular website and something just
pops up and it just works
I'm guessing everyone's getting a bit
tired of talking about chat TPT so I'm
not gonna do that
but the language features that have been
added in c-sharp so far they feel like
they are familiar to a c-sharp developer
they have a purpose we can obviously
misuse all of it but we should try to
avoid doing that
uh if you've liked this I have a lot of
courses on pluralsight covering language
features of c-sharp asynchronous
programming which I also have a session
on at three o'clock today but there's a
whole lot of things to check out if
you'd like to again I hope you've
enjoyed this thank you so much for
coming please vote on your way out if
you didn't like this send me an email
and forget to vote
I'm kidding enjoy the rest of the
conference thank you so much
thank you